today on the matt well show the media
has found a new virus to fear monger
over monkey pox but the public health
messaging around this disease has been
quite a bit different from what we heard
for kovid i'll explain why also nancy
pelosi is finally told that she has to
stop receiving communion at church on
account of her advocacy for baby
butchery a newly engaged aoc gives her
thoughts on the life question and her
thoughts are as stupid as you've come to
expect a gender affirming
psychotherapist says that sex education
in kindergarten is too late it should
really start at birth she says and our
daily cancellation a trans activist
reacts to my what is a woman trailer and
is not too pleased i can tell you we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
you know helix sleep has a quiz that
takes just two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for somebody else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers or as i
call them just a fat guy in a mattress
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door shipped for
free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store ever again just go to
helixsleep.com welsh take their two
minutes sleep quiz and they'll match you
to a customized mattress that'll give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but i guarantee you will
helix even has a financing options and
flexible payments plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners this is their
best offer yet so hurry over to
helixsleep.com
walsh
there are something like 200 viruses
circulating in the human population at a
any given time many of them potentially
fatal and that doesn't include all the
other causes of contagious disease like
bacterial infections and the other
ailments that are not contagious but
still deadly like cancers
so if for some reason you're looking for
a reason to be
paralyzed with fear and anxiety on a
monday uh you could pick
any of these illnesses at random and
just obsess over them if you want to
or you could wait for the media to
select it for you and if that's your
strategy then you have no doubt already
updated your scary disease rankings and
you've taken covet down a notch and
you've put monkey pox at the top
monkey pox by the way got its name
because it was first detected in a few
monkeys back in the 70s but monkeys are
not a major carrier of the virus
according to scientific american and
they didn't first jump into the human
population from monkeys actually rodents
are probably the natural reservoir for
the disease which means by all rights it
should be called rat pox
which makes it sound even scarier so
it's kind of a missed opportunity i
think rodent pox or rat pox
but any case rat pox aka monkey pox has
become the disease du jour as the media
attempts to stoke panic over the fact
that a few dozen people in the world
have been diagnosed with it in the last
few days and potentially as many as
three
three dear god in the united states have
been diagnosed with the disease or
potentially have the disease
if you're wondering whether you have
monkey pox right now you should know
that it first presents with a flu-like
symptoms which is also how you know how
covid presents so if you have a cough
right now or a runny nose
just relax it's probably not monkey pox
probably just covet or you know any of
the diseases of any dozens of other
illnesses that cause these exact
symptoms could be any of those
after about a week the monkey pox victim
will break out into rashes and lesions
and um
that's when i think when that happens
like if you've had the cough for a week
and then you have the lesions then you
can have your official oh crap this
might be monkey pox moment the good news
is that the disease is not easily
transmitted which is why
there was a quote outbreak in this
country in 2003 and only 70 people were
infected nobody died
now the media is telling us that the
disease has a 10 mortality rate which
means that there should have been
several deaths during the last outbreak
but what they forget to mention is that
the mortality rate is based mostly on
cases in africa where people die of all
kinds of diseases that kill almost
nobody in the developed world
you may be wondering why you never heard
of the great monkey pox outbreak of 2003
probably because that was before social
media
and also before the news media decided
that every scary sounding viral
infection contracted by anyone anywhere
in the world
needs to be headline news
but
does the fact that this virus is not
very contagious
and is not widely spread
and is not nearly as lethal as they're
making it sound
does that all mean that we should just
ignore monkey pox and go about our lives
i mean yes it does mean that that's
actually basically what it means over
the weekend joe biden told americans
that they should be concerned about
monkey box
and that's this administration's only
sales pitch their only message about
anything
they're just constantly telling us new
things to be terrified of monkey pox
coved white supremacists climate change
the great maggot king donald trump etc
and so forth
biden promised us a winter of death
uh you know last winter because of covet
which went into our spring of sorrow and
now we'll have our summer of suffering
to be followed by the fall of fear
this is this is all they want they just
want you to be twisting around endlessly
and a spiral of fear
and you should not give them what they
want
and yet
there is still something
worth noticing maybe not about monkey
pox itself but about the the monkey pox
discourse we'll call it
one of the one of the reasons why in
fact i'm not personally worried about
this virus is that
for this round of it anyway
it appears to be primarily spread
through sexual contact
as the sydney morning herald reports uh
in their headlines sexual form of monkey
pox blamed for global spread of virus
i'm not personally worried about any
stds at all because i'm in a faithful
and loving marriage with my wife
so score another point for faithful and
loving marriages that's not like the
number one reason to get married
but it's it's a nice perk
all these diseases people are worried
about you don't have to worry about it
you're fine
this one in particular falls outside of
my own lived experience because it seems
to be primarily infecting gay men the
world world health organization said as
much in a statement on the virus they
said based on currently available
information cases have mainly but not
exclusively been identified amongst men
who have sex with men
msm is what they're calling them which
is also
the acronym for mainstream media so
do with that what you will um with men
having sex with men seeking care and
primary care and sexual health clinics
that's from the uh world health
organization health officials have
determined that the likely super
spreader event in this case was a gay
pride festival in spain earlier in the
month
and the gay news site pink news
describes the gay pride event
as actually a fetish festival that's how
they describe it
the article also notes that more cases
are linked to a gay bath house in spain
or a sauna as it's euphemistically
dubbed
so there's there's still plenty that's
not known about this current outbreak if
we can call it an outbreak but
the link to gay sexual activity has been
established well enough that
organizations like who are reporting it
in fact as gb news reports this morning
gay men in the uk may be offered a
monkey pox vaccine uh first in a quote
targeted rollout
because of this connection that people
are noticing apparently nine brits have
been diagnosed so far and all but three
of them are gay
and this is
certainly not the first time that
viruses and other diseases have
circulated through
fetish festivals and bath houses
a bath house is after all essentially a
petri dish for disease
there really isn't any healthy or safe
way to have sex with random strangers
as the std epidemic in the us clearly
attests
now the good news
is that there is a simple solution here
which would tamp down the monkey pox
situation and also have the immense
added benefit of preventing the spread
of all kinds of other diseases many of
them much worse than monkey pox
and that is to refrain from having sex
with strangers
at a bath house
or anywhere else
and to forgo trips to fetish festivals
or any other event where you know large
groups of naked or semi-naked people are
swapping bodily fluids
again it would be best to avoid this
kind of behavior
in general even if monkey pox didn't
exist
so you would think that our public
health authorities
especially because they're so apparently
worried about monkeybox
you'd think they would spread this
message far and wide they would say you
know don't don't do these kinds of
things don't participate in these kinds
of activities
but they're not
instead rather than recommending that
people make healthy choices to avoid
spreading disease our so-called public
health authorities are more concerned
with the spread of stigma in this case
it's stigma stigma is the real disease
so the joint united nations program on
hiv and aids has been releasing
statements decrying the stigmatizing
language related to monkey pox and
they're worried about reporting that
might quote reinforce homophobic and
racist stereotypes and exacerbate stigma
andrew lee professor of public health at
the university of sheffield just
published an article cautioning against
germ panic okay
cautioning against germ panic as he
calls it
and warning that the real risk faced by
gay men is unfair stigma
then there's a professor uh who
researches epidemiology at yale greg
gonzalez
and he was more explicit in his
messaging he posted a lengthy thread to
twitter saying
and i'm going to read it here he says
i'm not an expert on the pathogen but
right now many of the cases are in gay
men and i know something about
infectious diseases among men who have
sex with men
first it is not a gay disease
if you are saying it is you are
perpetuating stigma and ignorance
damaging the public health response to
this and endangering lives
the disease spreads by close physical
contact and this is the setting in which
most cases have been found in this
global set of outbreaks most likely
disseminated via large social events
the answer
isn't
shut down all these parties tell gay men
to stop having sex at them or dancing in
close proximity to each other
it won't work
it hasn't worked for hiv or other kinds
of infectious disease outbreaks among
gay men
ah okay
now
it should come as no surprise that greg
here was an outspoken advocate of covet
lockdowns and highly critical of anybody
who protested them
so
according to greg
and many of his fellow public health
experts
it would be onerous and unfair and
unrealistic and oppressive and
stigmatizing to tell gay men to refrain
from having orgies at fetish festivals
and bath houses in order to avoid monkey
pox and other diseases
yet
it was perfectly reasonable to tell the
entire world to shut down and to lock
our kids in our homes for a year
and to drastically alter every aspect of
our lives for years
in order to avoid covet
kids were never at any serious risk from
covid nor were they ever very likely to
transmit it and we always knew that
and yet we were told that it was good
and necessary to put their lives on hold
for this disease
like for our sake
but for gay men we can't even tell them
to put their fetish festivals on hold
it appears the only way to shut down the
fetish festival is to shut down
everything else in the world along with
it it's the only way you're doing it
and even then as we've seen that still
isn't necessarily enough to cancel
events that protected classes of people
want to attend which is why you know as
we know the blm riots were happening
with the approval of all the public
health experts um at the height of covet
so
really think about this for a second
close the schools
don't close the bath houses
that's that's the motto here
and i can think of no better summary of
our approach to public health
and everything else in society
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
many of us spend more time every day in
our office chairs than in our cars or
our beds unfortunately but you got to
make the best of it that's why it's so
important to invest in the right chair
to spend those hours with the right
level of support and comfort to get the
most productivity out of your day x
chair is what you need it's made my time
at my desk not only more productive but
it's honestly my favorite place to sit
for any reason
sounds kind of sad but okay not only
does xchair's patented dynamic variable
lumbar offer the ultimate customized
support but my ex chair can even give
give me a massage it can heat up or cool
down and now thanks to x chairs new
armrests i can even adjust my armrest to
the perfect position all these unique
x-chair features help the hours of my
desk fly by in complete comfort that's
why i love my ex share go to xjwalsh.com
right now that's the letter x chair
walsh.com or call one eight four four
four x chair for a hundred dollars off
your order xchair has a 30 day guarantee
of complete comfort and you can finance
your purchase for as little as 30 bucks
a month again
xchairwalsh.com
all right so
we'll start with this from the daily
wire here's some um
some good news
a little bit of good news here daily
wire says the archbishop of san
francisco has informed speaker of the
house nancy pelosi that she is not to
receive holy communion at mass over her
repeated support
of abortion
he says in a statement in light of my
responsibility as the archbishop of san
francisco i am hereby notifying you that
you are not to present yourself for holy
communion
and should you do so you are not to be
admitted to holy communion until such
time as you publicly repudiate your
advocacy for the legitimacy of abortion
and confess confess and receive
absolution of this grave sin in the
sacrament of penance um pelosi still as
far as i know has not she didn't respond
to daley wire with a comment obviously
but i don't think she's spoken about
this publicly at all
um because it's uh it's
puts her in a very difficult position
thankfully
and it's not that the archbishop put her
in a difficult position she's put
herself in this position by
at once claiming she's a devout catholic
but then also supporting abortion so
she's been in this
position for decades
and it just took someone in the church
in a position of authority to uh call
her out on it and finally somebody has
um
continuing with the statement says this
fundamental moral truth has consequences
the fundamental truth about the dignity
of life in the womb
this fundamental moral truth has
consequences for catholics and how they
say they live their lives especially
those entrusted with promoting and
protecting the public good of society
pope john uh pope saint john paul ii was
also quite consistent upholding this
constant teaching of the church and
frequently reminded us that those who
are directly involved in law making
bodies have a grave and clear obligation
to oppose any law that attacks human
life
and the full statement it goes on longer
than that it's it's worth uh going and
looking up and reading it
because it's um
eloquently stated
and it also states what the catholic
position is here
and it's an example of
courage
you know actual courage
on the part of uh
church leadership in the united states
and there has not been a whole lot of
that in recent decades so
when you get an example of it it's worth
uh celebrating
even if there's also it's kind of a
bittersweet celebration because one of
the reasons you're celebrating is that
this is so rare
like
nancy pelosi should have been publicly
told years ago that you can't receive
communion and this should be every
bishop
in every diocese should be saying this
to
you know anyone in a in a public
position who supports abortion
um
but of course the media they're not
happy about this there's a uh
article in the san francisco examiner
which
this is the argument they're putting for
they're saying in open defiance of pope
francis
um
san francisco archbishop salvatore
cordeliani on friday banned house
speaker nancy pelosi from taking holy
communion here in her home diocese the
reason her strong support of women's
abortion rights
his decree was guaranteed to provoke
deep chagrin among san francisco
catholics and non-catholics alike
um and then the article goes on to claim
that this is in this is
in a contradiction of pope francis
another thing we're hearing from the
media a lot actually is that is that the
archbishop in san francisco is
contradicting is rebelling against pope
francis because pope francis has said
allegedly
that pro-abortion politicians should be
able to receive the eucharist and that's
not true at all that's actually not what
pope francis has
said and if he had said that i'd be
willing to admit it and call him out for
it denounce it because pope francis has
unfortunately said a lot of things
that he shouldn't say and are not
consistent with catholic teaching but
that's not one of them
and also just it's funny to me when you
see these leftists many of whom are not
catholic pretending to care about the
hierarchy in the church pretending to be
offended
that an archbishop allegedly
is uh contradicting pope francis this is
not the hierarchy you should respect the
po since would you care about that and
by the way if you do care about the
hierarchical structure of the church and
who has power to make what declarations
well the archbishop has the authority to
do this
and so if you care so deeply about the
hierarchy of the church
then what you should be saying to nancy
pelosi is you should respect this
because your archbishop has said it
i also think it's funny in this article
when they say it's uh it's provoked deep
chagrin among catholics and
non-catholics alike first of all let me
say if you're not a catholic
um your opinion about this is completely
irrelevant
and the reason why it's irrelevant is
because
this is about the
uh the catholic faith
the doctrines of the catholic church
and a lot of this rests on of course the
the moral doctrines of the catholic
church which are very clear on abortion
and have always been
like there's no debate about this there
never has been any debate about it
it is a it is a a moral teaching of the
church
that human life begins in the womb
that human life in the womb has
intrinsic value and dignity and to kill
that life is a deep grave moral crime
okay so
this is why it doesn't even make any
sense to be a pro-abortion catholic
because the only way to be a
pro-abortion catholic is to reject the
moral authority of the church
there's no other way to do it
you you can't cling on to your support
for abortion
while also clinging to the moral
authority of the church it's one of the
other these are mutually exclusive
things here
and if you believe that the church
doesn't have moral authority well fine
you're allowed to believe that
uh
given that we don't actually live in a
catholic theocracy
even if even if it were otherwise if i
had to say it but but i don't
because my theocratic regime has not
taken has not yet taken over so we're
not living with you so you can you can
have that opinion that the church
doesn't have any moral authority but
then you can't be catholic
so i'm a catholic but i don't believe
that the church has any moral authority
so it was not
instituted by christ then we must assume
uh or or it was but you don't think that
jesus christ is moral authority like how
does this work it's incoherent
so you give up
the idea that the church has more
authority you're giving up on the church
which again you're allowed to do in
america but then don't go around
claiming catholic it doesn't make any
sense
aside from the the
the scandal and everything the moral
scandal involved and everything else is
also just it's a logically incoherent
and this is also why the opinion of
non-catholics about who receives
communion is completely irrelevant
because
the issue comes down to the moral
teachings of the church and also
the doctrine of the real presence
in in the eucharist
that christ is really present in the
eucharist and it's not a that this is
not a
sort of symbolic gesture as they believe
in many protestant churches so if you
don't believe i either in either either
of those things the real presence in the
eucharist or the moral authority church
then obviously you're not going to
care who takes communion as far as
you're concerned anybody should be able
to take it
because you don't share those beliefs
that's why it's this is a catholic issue
um and if you are catholic again
it does not make any sense
to
support abortion
as a catholic or to say that
pro-abortion politicians should be able
to receive the eucharist
and the reason why you do this is
because you want
the catholic church
and the catholic faith to work like you
want everything else in life to work
you want it all to be sort of your
plaything and everything to be relative
to your own desires and feelings
you know you don't really want to be a
catholic you want to have your you've
created your own religion your religion
of the self for yourself as a leftist
and but you want to put a little bit of
catholic dressing over top of it
it's like you want to take the the
priestly robes and just kind of drape
them over top your
self-worshiping religion
um moving on aoc also had some thoughts
on abortion that she shared
and not much more coherent than
nancy pelosi's thoughts on the subject
but let's listen to that for people who
say oh but you're you know
you're you're harming a life i believe
this is life well some religions don't
so how about that
our jewish brothers and sisters they are
able to have an abortion according to
their faith you know
there are so many faiths
that
do not have the same definition of life
as
fundamentalist christians
and so
we how what about their rights
what about their right to exercise their
faith
it's ridiculous
and it is it's
it is theocratic it's authoritarian
it is
wrong uh once again what's the rule here
that we've talked about is when religion
is introduced to the topic of abortion
it's almost always a leftist introducing
it
because that's what they want this to be
they want they actually want this to be
a religious conversation
and so her rebuttal
uh to the claim that
that that human life exists in the womb
her rebuttal is well other religions
feel differently
which first of all
who cares
got nothing to do with anything
you're the one trying to make this
religious because you don't want to have
this argument on any other grounds you
want to make it totally sort of act like
it's completely subjective and it's all
based on you know you want to make it
all doctrinal right
you want to make it nothing but
doctrinal like we all have our competing
doctrines and nobody really knows what's
going on there's no
there's no
self-evident demonstrable reality at the
center of it that's how you wanna that
that's what you want to pretend but
there is
because at the center of this discussion
there is an actual
being in the womb that like exists
and so we can look there and say well
what what is that
and what is that and what you find is
that when you're actually having the
what is that conversation
it it's not religious at all there's no
reason why it's religious
it's actually a scientific it's first
and foremost number one actually a
scientific question
when you have a a
living being
and we want to know what what what what
is that
that's that's first and foremost a
scientific question
and we know that it's a human because it
has human parents
and we know that it's living
because it's growing and developing
non-living things don't do that
you know a non-living inanimate object
isn't you could have this table here
right
and you could just let the table sit let
it sit for hundreds of years and it'll
decay it'll fall apart it's not gonna
ever become
anything that we would all recognize as
a living thing
you could even take it and chop it up
and build it into something else and
it's still not gonna be a living thing
um so she wants to make it a religious
conversation first of all and then she
also of course misrepresents other
religions
she just declares that well jewish
people all support abortion
i don't know maybe check by
maybe ask
that'll come as news to ben shapiro
because i know he doesn't support
abortion as an orthodox jew
that's uh that's that'll be interesting
news
for him to learn
from aoc who's not jewish so do you know
that this is what your religion teaches
this is what non-religious people do
they do it to they do it to jews they do
it to catholics all the time we just we
just heard it in that uh san francisco
examiner article
they're constantly telling us what we
believe
even though they have no frame of
reference they have no clue at all
all right uh but we should say actually
uh congratulations anyway to aoc because
she did just get engaged
i would be uh remiss if i didn't mention
she did get she got engaged to her
longtime boyfriend and uh she
was bragging about the fact that she has
a zero emissions diamond that was given
to her as her engagement ring
because that's important to her
and you know she probably did ask that
like whatever the scenario was when uh
riley
her boyfriend i think that's his name
proposed
pulls the ring out before she even said
yes i could totally imagine the first
thing she has is that zero emissions
and then he said uh yeah
well well then i then yes let's get
married and he would and but his answer
saying it's zero emissions of course
that
doesn't mean anything
because how can you have a zero
emissions diamond what does that even
mean
i assume what you're trying to say is
that it was made like in a you know it
was manufactured like in a laboratory
they didn't dig it out of a out of a
mine
and so you're saying it's well there's
zero emissions so you're saying that it
was it was manufactured in a way that
produces no emissions it doesn't make
any sense at all that's i can tell you
right now that's impossible okay
you cannot
manufacture
anything in a way that doesn't produce
emissions impossible
anyway
all right last week we played some clips
first shared and reported by chris
rouffeau of a training session from the
far left lgbt extremist group the
mazzoni center and if you remember this
was a conference attended by
philadelphia teachers and also by kids
and minors were attended invited to
attend this conference as well
and there was a lot of depraved stuff we
don't have to go through all of it but
you can go back and watch that show if
you want to some examples
they had all kinds of you know they
people presenting information about uh
you know
sex toys and everything else like to
teachers for some reason
and now we have more footage um
this is from rachel simon she's the
woman in the video she's a trans
affirming quote unquote psychoanalyst
and i want you to listen to what she
says listen
i am rachel simon i use she her pronouns
i am a psychotherapist educator
consultant and author
i run my private practice here in
philadelphia
and i am the author of the every body
book which is a
an lgbtq inclusive
sex ed resource for seven to twelve year
olds i love that you said that this this
talk specifically was geared towards
teens but you're so right that sexuality
education starts
the minute you're born i mean we ha
we're born with bodies these bodies are
cool we want to touch our bodies we're
learning about um privacy and you know
being
sexual in public from a very early age
drop the cons of talking about sexuality
with parents and getting our sexual info
from parents in the chat
um because we're getting some of that
embarrassment awkwardness those can be
cons
they don't want to talk about it
uh homophobic and transphobic ideas from
parents can absolutely be a problem
inescapable judgment
yeah bigoted misinformed parents who
have no idea how to talk about gay sex
they're biased if they are religious it
can be very difficult to get into the
conversation with them yeah sometimes
you can get stonewalled out of
information
so psychotherapist there sorry sorry i
misgendered her as a psychoanalyst she's
a psychotherapist
and uh what's her message well i don't
bother talking to your parents you know
they're religious and bigoted don't
don't bother talking to them
uh but sexuality education begins at
birth she says
now i have to keep banging this drum
here because it's important to point out
where this stuff comes from
and that is
and all of the sex ed stuff comes from
alfred kinsey originally and that is
alfred kinsey to a t
that children are sexual
from birth literally from infancy
and as you're familiar with if you
listen to this show uh and we've talked
about before some of the horrific
details around that
pervert's life uh he he
actually
tried to prove
through sexual experiments on on young
babies that babies are quote sexual from
birth um
and uh
so sexual from birth
so we're gonna do sexuality education
for
infants now
i guess
see we're we're all we're we're behind
the eight ball because we're sitting
here saying
what do you mean anyway dude sex
education in kindergarten this is
ridiculous that's way too young
but what the left is saying is that no
that's too late
you talk about too young if anything
like by kindergarten they're five years
old that's that's that's five prime
years of
sexualizing
that they've missed out on they're
telling us
and then she also says
she gets more and more disturbingly
specific she says that uh from a very
young age we're learning about being
sexual in public
that's what
what are you talking about
but of course nobody
these people they're always running
unopposed as it were and uh you're only
ever going to hear them talking into a
camera
on a conference like this or on stage in
front of like mind a like-minded
audience of degenerates and perverts um
they're never going to put themselves in
a position where there's going to be any
follow-up questions
so they could just say stuff like this
you know because if there was a
follow-up question then the follow-up
would be what no no back up a second
little kids being sexual in public what
the hell are you saying
explain that to me
is that what you think when you see kids
out in public that's what you think
they're
doing
go ahead explain
and we know whatever the explanation is
it's not gonna there's there's no way to
make that any less depraved
and this again is this was a training
session
at least in part for
teachers
this is what teachers are being told
all right the daily mail has this the
man who attacked dave chappelle on stage
at a los angeles comedy show earlier
this month said he was triggered
by the comedian's jokes about gay people
and also about homelessness
and he told chappelle he should be more
sensitive
isaiah lee was charged with four
misdemeanors after the may third attack
misdemeanors okay
battery possession of a weapon with
intent to assault unauthorized access to
stage area during a live performance and
commission of an act that delays the
event or interferes with the performer
so
battery
and possession of a weapon with
attention to assault that's work so
those are good misdemeanors for this for
this guy
um he was contacted by the new york post
and he said that uh that he's this is
what he said he said quote i identify as
bisexual and i wanted him to know what
he said was triggering
i wanted him to know that next time he
should consider first running his
material by people it could affect
okay
so a couple of things here now we now we
understand um why this guy got off with
a misdemeanor when he charged on stage
during an event
assaulted somebody with a knife
with a knife that oddly enough he had
disguised as a gun so we've already
tried to figure that out i don't know
exactly how that that works you know um
he's like you don't want security to
know you have a knife so instead you
just pretend you have a gun i don't know
but he got through security anyway
and he was charged with misdemeanor and
now we know why because he's a member of
a protected class
he's a member of you know the group that
even during a virus outbreak you can't
uh tell them to not go to a you know
fetish festival or a bath house
um
so that's that's the first thing that's
why that's why that happened because
he's a member of the protected class
and this is also
more confirmation
that all of this you know these attacks
against dave chappelle and in particular
it's not just like
the criticizing dave chappelle leads to
people trying to kill him on stage
that's not the point
you could you could criticize somebody
without provoking anyone else to attack
them
but
when you're claiming relentlessly that
dave's that words are violence
and that and that just by saying words
dave chappelle could be hurting and
potentially killing people because
that's what they say
just with dave chappelle's jokes about
trans people
all of which are are mild okay
um
but those jokes could lead to death it
could be killing people
so when you when you say that enough
about somebody
uh then yeah and then at the same end
also you you you have these protected
privileged classes of people who could
basically do whatever they want
um especially if they're acting out
emotionally and they feel quote unquote
triggered
you put all that together then you're
creating you know that's that's the
recipe for something like this
and of course the last little
ingredient in the recipe
is
will smith charging the stage and
assaulting someone during the oscars and
then a lot of people on the left were
making excuses for him
and and saying that at least well it's
uh
it's not good but it's not any worse
than making a gi jain joke about a bald
woman
so you add all those things together and
uh this is what happens now it's
interesting that the
assailant here
says that he he the reason he did it is
he wants
dave chappelle to be too afraid next
time to make jokes like this so that's
also terrorism by the way trying to use
fear to manipulate people using fear to
bring about a certain political or
ideological end that's that's terrorism
so this should be you should be brought
up not on a misdemeanor but on terrorism
charges like if you really cared about
about stopping this from happening in
the future that's what you would do
but they don't want to stop this from
happening in the future they agree with
him that's that is the message to dave
chappelle
from his assailant
and from the media in the left as well
oh you didn't you didn't like getting
assaulted by a guy with a knife in the
middle of a performance well just don't
make jokes about us
that's all
make jokes about everybody else but just
not us because we're special
finally it's from the jerusalem post it
says a scientist may have pinpointed the
origin of the wow signal the most famous
alien radio broadcast in history making
an ideal candidate for future research
and observations in the search for
extraterrestrial terrestrial
intelligence
the study which was um
polished in the
i assume that's supposed to say
published was published in the peer
review academic periodical the
international journal of astrobiology
suggests that the famous signal could
very well have come from a star located
in the sagittarius constellation that is
similar to our own
the wow signal is easily the most famous
and enduring extraterrestrial radio
transmission to earth and history this
day it's the strongest candidate for a
genuine radio transmission from an
intelligent source the signal itself
and you know what never mind because you
guys don't care about this do you like
i'm just sitting here reading this
nobody cares
nobody cares about the space and alien
stuff it's just me why do i even bother
i'm gonna go cry i'm gonna go lock
myself in the bathroom now and cry
after the show cause we gotta get to our
comment section right now
[Music]
marley says my brother's biology teacher
is refusing to say male or female and
instead describes the body parts one has
my brother watches your show and emailed
and spoke to the teacher about how wrong
it was thank you for being such a great
role model well
thank you to uh your brother because
this is it's really sad
to put it
you know lightly
that um kids
in school have to be put in this
position where they have to correct
their biology teachers on basic human
biology but that's exactly what needs to
happen
and so um
it's good that your your brother did
that
and uh hopefully your parents are
encouraging it cause i could tell you
even when i went to school going to
public school this is this was
you know public schools were
bastions of sanity uh when i went
compared to now anyway but even back
then they were bad
by their own standards and this is one
thing that my parents used to used to
tell me it's like respect your teachers
okay
respect your elders
but
if you're being lied to
and they're saying things that are that
are not true and they're lying to you
then you should speak up and if you get
in trouble at home you know if you get
in trouble at school you will not be in
trouble at home for that
so that's great from your brother
donald says the musk accusation isn't a
she said she said situation it's a they
said she said she said she said yeah
you're right actually it's well it's so
it's it's
we're being told by the media
that
they were told by a woman
who was told by another woman
who claims that she was sexually
harassed by elon musk so yeah there's
like four or five degrees of separation
there
um
aaron says matt i'm new to your show
this week and finding your logic and
insight refreshing i also recognize that
the subjects you dive into are extremely
dark and troubling to say the least
without intending to sound cliche or
silly i would purpose to pray for your
strength and peace thanks for your
boldness to fight inspiring others to
take a stand as we're intended to do
well i appreciate your prayers i don't
complain about it i don't mention this
too much because i like i don't it's i
don't want to come off as overly
dramatic and without being traumatized
you know
but
in my own small little way being totally
immersed in this kind of stuff every day
does take a little bit of a toll on you
so i appreciate your prayers and you
know especially because i try to br i
want to break up
all of the deep dark depressing stuff by
talking about space and aliens but i
can't even do that because i get made
fun of so
that just makes the trauma even worse
um samantha says
absolute fun sponges karen jean pair
makes me laugh out loud every time i
hear it well thank you smith so you and
i elise can have fun with that
um
and uh
let's see and finally tony says can't
help but notice matt has gone quiet
about his interpretive dance promise
the numbers are almost there of a
feeling after june 1st
it will reach
1 million i don't know what promise
you're talking about
i don't remember i've
because i covered so that's uh it
supposedly affects your memory right
that's what so i'll go with that i have
long coveted
so i can't remember anything that i said
prior to right now so unfortunately
if you've followed the daily wire for
any amount of time you know that we're
fixated on the truth whether it's our
journalists exposing the cover-up of a
sexual assault in virginia schools or
hosts like myself just trying to get a
straight answer to a simple question
like what is a woman as i do in my
documentary of that name out on june 1st
well over the last few months our very
own candace owens has been digging into
the 90 million bag of abject lies that
is black lives matter and she's come up
with her hands full i can tell you that
her daily wire original the greatest lie
ever told george floyd and the rise of
blm is on its way and it's going to be
pure kryptonite we had planned to
release it this week but as you can
imagine when you start a documentary you
never fully know where the facts will
lead what candace has uncovered on this
journey is going to blow some people's
minds so we're going to take some time
to finalize the film and make sure every
last damning detail sees the light of
day believe me it'll be worth the wait
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have another
case of a daily cancellation inception
where we respond to somebody responding
to me in this case it's jamie raines who
uh wikipedia tells me is an english
youtuber with over 900 000 subscribers a
research psychologist and lgbt advocate
reigns has a phd in psychology and has
disturbingly quote conducted research
into the sexual response of transgender
men
reigns is also a self-professed quote
unquote trans man
um there have been many youtube
responses to the trailer for my film
what is a woman also many responses on
other platforms including on twitter
where the primary response from the left
on twitter has been to mass report it
and try so far unsuccessfully to get it
pulled from the site so i'm getting like
i'm getting these email notifications
about reports people reporting the
trailer
you know multiple times a day
but i'm choosing rains to respond to
because this is a channel with more
subscribers than i have and somebody
with um
much more formal education than i have
so nobody can accuse me of punching down
not that there's anything wrong with
punching down mind you i'm a firm
believer that one should punch in
whichever direction needs to be punched
but we'll focus here for now the video
is uh over 10 minutes long so we won't
be able to pick it apart piece by piece
but we'll watch enough to get the point
surely i mean this phd psychologist and
lgbt activist will be able to swiftly
debunk the entire premise of my film and
utterly humiliate me in the process
i'm just a transphobe with a high school
diploma after all
shouldn't be much of a challenge so
we'll see how our friend
jamie reigns does
it's called what is a woman from the
daily wire which i think i've heard of
made by somebody or involving heavily
somebody called matt walsh
[Music]
what is a woman immediately is he
wearing a sandwich board that says what
is a woman okay
can you tell me that
[Music]
oh you're at the women's march you must
have some idea please if one person can
tell me what a woman is you are not here
for women we ask you to leave what is
that what is that oh wow so a dude going
to a woman's march and going up to women
and asking them to define what a woman
is and probably acting like it's some
big gotcha moment yeah that's
interesting oh let's not forget the
sandwich board i mean what definition
was he looking for one based off of
genitals and reproductive organs that's
a little bit very narrow and not exactly
great to boil people down to their parts
okay well first of all jamie
how do you know i'm a dude i don't i
didn't tell you that
that was not that was not said
so where'd you get that from
and yeah it is a gotcha moment
in fact if people are marching in a
women's march and holding signs and
chanting slogans claiming that women are
under attack and being oppressed and yet
they have absolutely no idea what a
woman is and can't begin to define the
term then yes that's a gotcha moment as
it reveals the inherent absurdity and
incoherence of their worldview but it's
not a gotcha moment that i engineer
okay i'm not backing anybody into a
corner
all i did was
walk up to them and ask them what the
words they're using mean
that's a fair question in fact that's
the fairest question you can ever ask
anyone is when they're using words to
say what do you mean by that how could
that be an unfair question
if it becomes a gotcha moment for you
that only shows just how totally vapid
and ridiculous your ideology is as for
what kind of definition i'm looking for
well to start with i'd like a definition
some kind of definition
let's just get a definition on the table
first and then we can debate whether
it's the right or wrong one but you guys
won't put any definition at all on the
table
you act like the word has no meaning at
all like it's just a bunch of arbitrary
gibberish and yet you continue to use
the word
and uh and you you and you expect us all
to know what it means or to know what
you mean when you use it so again is it
a gotcha yes it certainly is but i
didn't get you
you got yourself
all from the controversial mind of matt
walsh i'm a husband i'm a father for i
host a talk show i give speeches i write
books i like to make sense of things a
woman is not anything in particular
there is not one particular thing it
could be many things to many people some
women have penises right some men have
vaginas i like scented candles i've
watched sex in the city yeah how do i
know if i'm a woman oh dear god what is
he doing why is he making this do you
just show a compilation of people saying
it can't be boiled down to one thing
some women do have penises like trans
women some men do have vaginas like some
trans men and your response is i like
scented candles is that what makes a
woman
i don't know does it may you tell me
because a second ago you said that a
woman can't be defined by her parts
now you're saying that having an
interest in feminine things also doesn't
make you a woman so what does jamie
you've declared that neither interests
nor body parts define a woman which
would seem to indicate that you have a
solid idea in your head as to what does
define a woman and yet you have yet to
provide that definition
what if i decide that my love of scented
candles makes me a woman after all i'm
not just talking about the manly sense
okay like like uh
leather or bonfire or something i can go
with a lavender candle okay that's how
girly the candles can get sometimes
and if i say that makes me a woman who
are you to say that i'm wrong
you can only just dismiss my scented
candle based definition if you have some
other objective definition in mind but
if you don't
if you have no idea what a woman is then
for all you know no a woman is truly
just anyone who's purchased a scented
candle at any point in their life
that definition is at least better than
the definition you're offering
because you aren't offering any
you're not a scientist you're not a
gender studies major no how do you know
that you're a man i guess because i got
a dick
a journey to discover the truth the
truth about mom
the truth about what a woman is it's
right there in the title
how are you confused already that's what
this is about try to keep up jaime
can a man
become a woman
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not a woman so i
i can't really answer that women only
know what women are
can a man become a woman that's a silly
question because trans women are not men
who become women they are women who
happen to be trans just like trans men
are not women who become men we're men
who happen to be trans at least ask the
right questions
well this is this is shocking
i'm appalled
jamie are you suggesting that gender is
not fluid
like ninety percent of people on tick
tock identify as gender fluid do they
not exist
does tic toc not exist are you saying
their identities are not valid are you
marginalizing gender fluid people
because in fact according to your
worldview
a man can absolutely become a woman
an individual could identify as a man
one day and a woman the next
so in fact an individual could identify
as a man one minute and a woman the next
and each of those identities are valid
and true right isn't that what you think
if you are whatever you identify as and
you identify as a woman after having
identified as a man
that would mean that you became a woman
you were one thing and now you're
another so you became the other
unless gender fluidity is false
which is that what you believe
you're a fluid phobe
duly noted jamie
are you a uh cat no can you tell me what
a cat is
you want to tell us what a woman is ah
yes i mean i don't know if this is
lovely editing or if this is actually
how it went down but ask somebody to
define an animal yeah that really makes
sense asking someone to define an animal
that has nothing to do with the human
concept and language of gender and sex
is really not the clever move he thinks
it is i could bring up the example when
a well-known transphobe tried to define
a chair and then multiple people pointed
out to him that that definition could
also work for horses so well done a
horse is now a chair apparently
no see you're you're confused again the
point of the cat question was not to
quiz that person by the definition of a
cat
the point was to respond to the claim
that only women can know what women are
and first of all as i discovered the
women's march that's not true because
lots of women don't know what women are
and second
you can absolutely know what something
is without being that thing
everybody knows what a cat is and yet
none of us are cats
i also know what a chinese person is
despite not being chinese i know what
planets and sandwiches and mice and
trees and mark wahlberg is despite the
fact that i'm not any of those things i
even know what a chair is that's not a
hard question that's a seat built for
one person usually with four legs and a
back there you go that's a chair that
definition would not apply to horses
because horses aren't built okay
let's keep going i'm a biological woman
that medically transitioned to appear
like a male i will never be a man
oh
no abs no do not agree with that
99.99999
9
of trans men will very strongly disagree
with that statement don't know if that
person actually identifies as a trans
man by the sounds of it they are
assigned female at birth and
transitioned in the sense of taking
testosterone and living within society
as a man but yes sure for the purposes
of your seemingly transphobic
documentary
go and find one of the very very few
trans people who holds these kind of
gender critical transphobic views on
trans people and include them ignore the
many thousands in the vast vast majority
of trans people who will very strongly
disagree with this very very small
number of trans people who will say
things like this
but who cares if scott nugent's views
are in the minority among trans people
trans people are in the minority among
the general population if you can
dismiss scott for being the minority
then can't i dismiss
you for being in the minority
also i did not ignore other trans people
we talked to lots of trans people in the
film some of whom you've already seen in
the trailer despite claiming that we
ignored them we tried to speak to many
more trans people but they refused to
speak to us and this is a pretty common
phenomenon right trans activists claim
that nobody will talk to us
oh why don't you talk to us and yet when
i try to talk to them they literally run
away
i mean literally get up and run away in
some cases okay uh jumping ahead now we
get to the part of the trailer where i'm
talking to a gender affirming
pediatrician
about the quote unquote gender affirming
about the chemical castration drug she
gives to kids well i say i'm talking to
her about it but it's more accurate to
say that i tried to talk to her about it
she threatened to storm out of the
interview and as soon as i correctly
noted that the puberty blocker lupron is
used to chemically castrate pedophiles
and then that's what brings us to what
jamie has to say about all this let's
listen
puberty blockers have actually been used
in cis kids with precocious puberty for
a very long time decades as well decades
proposes puberty being when puberty
starts too early so they use puberty
blockers to hold it off a bit till the
child is a more appropriate age there
has never been a fuss over cis kids with
early puberty having access to puberty
blockers in the same way that there has
been a fuss over trans kids they're the
same drugs they're used in the same way
to hold off puberty until a child is
ready to go through puberty no one ever
gave a [ __ ] about puberty blockers until
it became widely known that they were
used to help trans kids
okay jamie leaning close here so you can
you can hear this i want you to hear it
so pay close attention
precocious puberty is a physical
condition it's an ailment often caused
by tumors on the ovaries or adrenal
glands or by problems with the nervous
system or genetic syndromes
precocious puberty happens when a
child's body is doing what it is not
supposed to do
naturally
that's why we call it precocious meaning
it's happening earlier than it's
supposed to
there are also direct physical
consequences to not treating precocious
puberty such as the potential for
stunted growth and other problems
but puberty blockers for quote trans
kids are used to treat quote unquote
puberty that is not precocious
there's no physical problem puberty is
happening exactly when it's supposed to
so on the one hand we have puberty
blockers used to treat early puberty in
children with a physical health
condition on the other we have puberty
blockers used to stave off normal
puberty in children with no relevant
physical health condition
it's it's very similar to the difference
between top surgery for physically
healthy girls and a double mastectomy
for someone with breast cancer
and you don't see a difference in these
two scenarios
the difference is that they are
literally opposites of each other that's
the difference
i know it might be a little too subtle
for you phds not the most perceptive
bunch i've learned
is it transphobic to tell the truth the
interview's over let's turn off the
cameras excuse me they're fair i just
wanted to know what is a woman and
you're not going to find out based on
what i'm saying would you ever want to
move to america they say
no
never
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
honestly that felt like a hot mess and
was just filled with all of the
transphobic dog whistles and transphobia
that was thinly veiled as caring about
children truth is these people the
people with these views in the
transphobic views and making films like
this will not have had any concern for
the cis kids receiving the exact same
treatment and i'm not saying they should
have what i'm pointing out is that they
all of a sudden have concern and are
pouring money and resources into making
stuff like this to just
on an incredibly discriminated against
community within society why
it doesn't make sense to me there's just
a lot of fear-mongering going around
there's a lot of misinformation there's
a lot of half-truths there's a lot of
dog whistles and there's a lot of people
buying into it when in reality trans
people
we just want to live our lives okay
trans kids deserve access to
transforming health care which again
just reminding you a majority of which
is purely just social and then the other
little bit is puberty blockers
so a lot to parse through here but i
couldn't help but note jaime that you uh
never said anything specifically about
the african tribe
i mean they were literally laughing at
the very idea of transgenderism and they
had a lot more to say which you'll see
in the film when it comes out on june
1st but you seem to let them off the
hook you called scott nugent at
transphobe and mia transphobe but you
seem somehow reluctant to call the call
out the bigotry of that group of
africans that i spoke to
which is kind of interesting
as for your claim at the end that uh
most trans affirming healthcare quote
unquote for kids is social and the rest
is puberty blockers well
you're lying
as you know kids are getting surgery as
young as 14 or even younger potentially
they're chopping the breasts off of
minors that's part of the
trans-affirming health care that you
seem to want to skate around
the puberty blockers we've already
covered they're not reversible they're
not safe and these are indeed the exact
same drugs they use to chemically
castrate convicted pedophiles
the social transition that you talk
about is designed to and almost always
has the effect of putting kids on the
path to medical transition a little
further down the line as you also know
so the distinction between social and
medical transition for kids is
misleading at best
but no surprise there as a trans
activist misleading people is what you
do best
speaking of which i noticed something
else jamie you you just gave a whole 10
minute response and yet you never did
actually respond to the question
kind of curious
your response could have been 15 seconds
you could have invalidated and debunked
the whole film humiliated me and scored
a major victory against transphobia
simply by providing a definition of
woman that's coherent and consistent
with gender ideology but you didn't
is that because you're
polite
so polite that you'll repeatedly accuse
me of bigotry and call the film a hot
mess but not provide the one thing that
would actually debunk the central
premise of the film
is it politeness or are you sitting on a
gigantic house of cards and you know it
and you know i know it but you don't
want anyone else to know it
well i guess that's just another
question that i'm
asking even though i already know the
answer
and that's why
you're canceled and that'll do it for us
today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22. a
new pandemic drops just in time for the
midterms the archbishop of san francisco
denies communion to nancy pelosi and
hispanics flee from the democrats
sinking ship check it out on the michael
knowles show